I think the stat is 78% of athletes go
bankrupt within two years
NFL players go bankrupt within two years
after they retire and you think yourself
like you made all this money how did you
not be smarter with it well they never
taught us in school how to manage our
finances
yeah and how to save money and how to
invest money then we'll teach you these
things when all you care about it's
sports so I didn't make that much money
playing arena football made $250 a week
and we had food stamps so I was living
in Huntsville Alabama and eating
chick-fil-a and whatever else I could
eat from the food stamps and so there's
no money guys saved my sister brought me
in and let me crash at her house it was
supposed to be for about a month I'm
once turned into a year and a half and
she gave me an incredible gift she said
okay you got to start paying rent after
a year and a half this is the Reuben
report and I'm still Dave Rubin friendly
reminder guys to subscribe to our
YouTube channel and click that pesky
notification bell so that you might just
see our new videos when they come out
and joining me today is a New York Times
bestselling author a business coach and
the host of the school of greatness
podcast lewis howes welcome to the
Reuben report on man thanks for having
me I'm glad to have you here we got to
get some some some simple stuff out of
the way there's anything first off I
love that freakin jacket I don't know
about that jacket I'm very jealous about
the jacket that's like on so low modern
I love it if clean right it's clean I
want that jacket just a little touch of
life the accents are super clean you put
anything in there I don't know it's good
I've only once a few times so I should
probably wear more I put this on for you
I knew you're gonna wear a jacket and I
normally just wear a black shirt yeah
but I was like let me wear something a
little bit nicer we're an actual
professional studio here I had to dress
up well you got a pretty professional
operation it's clean I mean I did your
podcast in the midst of a lockdown it's
the only live yes in-person interview
that I did in the whole thing we
actually shook hands
well we fist bumped and then we realize
that's just do it exactly actually shook
hands and then we found out right
afterwards that you hit the New York
Times bestseller list for your big blows
it was it was in your studio that I
found a magic happens with us
New York Times bestselling yeah there we
go there we go all right there's a ton I
want to talk to you about I'm glad we're
doing this because you know I do a lot
of politics in here I do a lot of
culture wars and all that but I think
underneath all of that is a human thing
that I think you are really excelling at
at the moment so before we get into that
though for the people that have no idea
who you are
who is Lois house how the hell did you
get that fancy jacket and what's he
doing here I'm a human being on a quest
to discover more of myself how it can
become better and how I can make a big
impact on the people around me and I've
always cared about human performance
I've always just wanted to excel at the
things I care about I think from an
early age I did it to try to prove
people wrong because I felt unseen
unheard on right unloved by everyone
around me and even though that wasn't
the truth that's just how I felt my
parents were there for me my older
siblings were there but I just didn't
feel like I fit in in a lot of ways and
especially in school I was very dyslexic
if I even try to read my own book could
probably be struggle reading my own
words that I wrote down just because
I've always struggled with that and I
was in special needs classes from as
long as I can remember during recess and
lunch breaks in school I would be with
tutors so I didn't get to do a lot of
the things that normal kids would do and
I just felt always insecure and
insignificant in my abilities and that
kind of stayed with me and I used sports
as my after-school kind of program to
say what can I do if school is something
I struggle in wearing in high school
they would I don't know if they did this
in your high school but they would
actually rank us in our class on our
report cards so I was always in the
bottom four of the student class like
purely younger they would like say like
here are a hundred students so I was
like always 96 out of a hundred or 100
out of 100 based on your GPA so I would
always see that number and read it every
quarter we would get our report card and
I'd always see them on the bottom four
and never broke out of the bottom four
in school so it's just a very
challenging time for me to to think
about and that's what we judged ourself
on in school growing up was like who can
read faster who's smarter who got A's
and who got
and so I used sports as my outlet to say
I'm you know I'm gonna become bigger
faster and stronger than everyone else
around me I'm gonna show them that I'm
worthy of love and worthy of their
attention I'm worthy of being picked
first not being last and I just put my
energy into that and made my dreams
around that because I started to get
really good at sports and that became
kind of my mission until I got injured
playing sports ends and then then my
dream my identity you know kind of falls
apart because I got injured playing
arena football and I had I mean this
isn't 2008 when the economy it was the
end of 2007 the economy is crashing I
remember I didn't have a college degree
yet as I left early to go play football
try to make the NFL wasn't good enough
to make it and I had no money I had
college debt that I was trying to pay
off I didn't have a job
and I remember trying to go on LinkedIn
to find jobs in 2007-2008 and no one was
hiring people without a college degree
in 2008 let alone with master's degrees
they were having a hard time getting a
job so I remember saying to myself what
am I going to do I'm sleeping on my
sister's couch at this time for a year
and a half trying to figure out one Who
am I I lost my dream I lost the ability
to work out at this moment everything I
put my identity around to is gone I have
no clue what to do next and this might
be a first world problem but for me my
identity was was gone and I didn't know
who I was in the world or why I wasn't
supposed to be here anymore how dark was
that time because you see you hear this
with athletes all the time major Pro
guys that you know they blow out the
knee and it's over and then you know you
find out that they're living on the
streets five years later all sorts of I
think the stat is 78 percent of athletes
go bankrupt within two years NFL players
go bankrupt within two years after they
retire and you think yourself like you
made all this money how did you not be
smarter with it well they never taught
us in school how to manage our finances
yeah and how to save money and how to
invest money they don't teach you these
things when all you care about it's
sports so I didn't make that much money
playing arena football made $250 a week
and we had food stamps I was living in
Huntsville Alabama and eating
chick-fil-a and whatever else I could
eat from the food stand
and so there's no money that I saved my
sister brought me in and let me crash at
her house who were supposed to be for
about a month I'm once turned into a
year and a half and she gave me an
incredible gift she said okay you got to
start paying rent after a year and a
half so that push finally got me to say
okay I need to learn if I'm not gonna go
get a job somewhere
I started truck driving for $250 a week
I was driving Napa car auto parts for
six hours a day 250 was your Suites 50
is my sweet spot I couldn't break that
limit so I was like how do I get past
this yeah and at the same time I was
also reaching out to people on LinkedIn
finding men trying to find mentors I was
just trying to interview people
personally and ask them questions about
how do I achieve anything after sports I
just had no clue how to do it and she
gave me a great gift she said you've got
to start helping and contributing to the
rent and I didn't know what I was gonna
do I really just like I don't know what
I'm gonna do but I applied for a job on
LinkedIn I found a sports marketing job
because I eventually graduated and
applied for a sports marketing job and I
got an interview my first ever interview
that I got and applying for a job and
for whatever reason I had my one nice
sport jacket from like college I dressed
up and I'm leaving the house at my
sister's house I open the door to walk
out to the street and I can't take a
step out of the house for whatever
reason I'm unable to actually leave the
house and shut the door behind me
because for whatever I was either so
egotistical at the moment or just
believed in myself so much that I was
like if I go to this interview I'm gonna
get the interview mm-hmm and I'm gonna
get the job and they're gonna hire me
because I'm gonna be so convincing that
they're gonna need me and then I'm gonna
stay here for two three years and I'm
not going to enjoy what I'm doing and
then I'm gonna feel trapped and stuck
and I just didn't want to go down that
route so that gave me the courage to say
okay I need to go figure out how to make
money on my own because I've never made
a dime I wasn't this entrepreneurial kid
doing lemonade stands and selling
baseball cards and making shoe
accessories or whatever in school I was
just trying to play sports and so I had
no entrepreneurial bone in my body but
the necessity to just survive and be
able to contribute to rent
and pay for my own food as a 24 year old
at the time 25 year old became apparent
and that was the push that I needed and
so I left my sister's house moved to my
brother's place and started paying him
guess how much - fifty to fifty a month
in rent and stayed there for about six
months and for whatever reason that
investment even though it's $250 was was
a way for me to think okay how do I make
five hundred a month so I can get a
month ahead how do I make a thousand a
month it just started getting me
thinking differently because I was
forced to and that was 2009 and here we
are now very journey so you mentioned
some of the growing up stuff and
self-esteem so I know it's not the most
fun thing to talk about in the world but
you were molested when you were five
years old yeah can you just break it
down a little bit you know because I
think it does sort of frame a lot yeah
frankly I look at the world obviously
well one in six men have been sexually
abused in some way in America which I
had no clue about these statistics until
I started to open up about my sexual
abuse and started to research it I just
thought I was the only boy that had ever
been abused and therefore I was
worthless I was helpless and if people
actually knew this about me they would
never love me they would never accept me
people would laugh at me and make fun of
me that was the fear inside if you'd
like to be inspired motivated and
educated by some of the most successful
people around the world check out the
school of greatness full episode
playlist right over here and if you'd
like to see Lois houses interview with
me click right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell